the guy just pulled up on a horse well
is he still on the horse he just went
inside the place problem solved
what you gonna do and call me when it's
done
okay I don't want to hurt you if you
could just pay Paulie the money that you
own coffee he's not staying
yes sir
hey is that guy dead
looks pretty dead
[Music]
it done I think I killed the cook this
is why I don't stand up for you this not
good though tomorrow first thing I want
you to go and see that degenerate cowboy
and straighten this out yeah I only
agreed to kill that guy Walter because
my kid's in jail I need the money to get
him away Welcome to the Jungle
we're in this together now yo Polly
Russo 100 Grand you got a week to come
up with the bread I got a lot of friends
law and otherwise you've always got to
forgive my death you really want to take
this road with me you are welcome to
find out my friend my son's detention
hearing is in three days I don't even
have the lawyer yet who talks Money
Talks yeah right maybe we can help each
other my mom's she's Rich get me out of
here your dad's working on it okay
that's supposed to make me feel better I
want you to find Jackie and I want you
to bring him to me directly
hey I'm supposed to be scared of you now
do you get a gun you are nothing but an
Aaron boy I'll bust your home okay all
right let me see it
hold on can I put my clothes on first
this way
oh god he's a keeper I will put up the
money for your son it seems like the
right thing to do he's known you for two
minutes she's ready to write you a check
this is very embarrassing I'll find Jack
Egan this time you're gonna Whack Him
come on boy do I look like I'm joking to
you you gotta go take care of my kids
[Music]
bottom line is you make some very
serious Bets with me you lost I don't
understand you mom because of dying or
because your acting career didn't work
out oh my God
this ain't me scared boy this is me
pissed off
stop it
do we have a lawyer
I'm sorry your honor I apologize I'm new
in town got a little lost
[Music]